CBS News has gained rare access inside
Syria which is now in its eighth year of
civil war Syrian regime forces have
begun a new bombing campaign and there
are fears that a full-scale offensive
could be next the province of Idlib home
to 3 million people is one of the last
remaining areas in western Syria that
the government does not control Holly
Williams recently returned from mid Lib
where she saw firsthand what life is
like for those living in constant fear
[Music]
Syria's war machines are menacing idly
there's no defense against regime and
Russian airstrikes just warnings to take
cover passed on by radio area and we're
hearing over the walkie-talkie that
there could be more planes leaving
regime bases we headed into an olive
grove where many in need Libba now
sheltering that was an airstrike under
the olive trees we found a brigade of
the white helmets there the rescue teams
we've pulled survivors from the wreckage
of airstrikes but last month they said
one of their buildings was bombed now
they're moving location every day to
avoid being targeted again the town of
marat herma was hit by regime
helicopters the night before we were
told our boss tafe wanted to get his
message to the world the kids are all
dead he said we need the powerful
countries to help us oh the trauma of
eight years under fire is palpable it
lives now home to hundreds of thousands
of men women and children who fled the
bombing and a living in tents mother had
like Marwa armored and her eight
children she's pregnant and told us
she'll give birth here on the dirt
do you see these kids she asked us
they're not kids anymore there are over
a million children in Italy according to
the United Nations and they are
especially vulnerable pro-regime forces
have hit both schools
and hospitals a Syrian opposition
monitoring group said there were 35
airstrikes the day that we were there
and that according to our guides was a
good day
Adriana Polly Williams an Istanbul Thank
You Holly that's just heartbreaking how
the children are being affected there